hi my name is Jared wazian and i'm here
with the global changemakers from the
British Council but it also in an
organization that raises awareness about
climate change through arts my question
is why aren't there more government
sponsored initiatives that are go into
the creativity of the young people give
them the opportunities for to unleash
their creativity simultaneously raising
awareness about global issues such as
climate change public health education
and literacy we need these these are
absolutely imperative for the
Advancement of the young people because
we need to get them involved we need to
make sure they are not apathetic we to
give them the opportunities to involve
themselves and to prepare to inherit all
these problems because at the end of the
day they will be the future leaders of
tomorrow and they will be the people
here at the World Economic Forum in 20
years time